we have our clinical pharmacist who
works there our physiotherapist who
works there Dr Mehta doesn't normally
have the luxury of an empty surgery to
show journalists like me around it's a
really bustling place on a Monday
morning the government wants to improve
patient access to doctors like him
firstly by spending over two million
pounds on new telephone systems to make
sure every patient's call is answered
it's not only about access it should be
about the continuity of care so as GP
practices we know our populations we
know our patients we know when they come
in and they are more needy than other
times so I think if we if we just look
along access and just providing them
with more and more appointments as
opposed to providing them with
Continuous Care we might end up in a bit
of trouble
1600 patients are registered at this
practice and every morning sees the same
chaotic dash for appointments the
practice is closed but already the
phones are going normally you'd have
four receptionists here Fielding calls
from hundreds of patients all trying to
make appointments for that day the
government says it wants to move away
from this 8 A.M scramble the doctors
here say the situation every morning is
manic
doctors want the investment but it
doesn't address the workforce crisis
that is driving the pressure in Primary
Care the numbers of GPS in the UK is
dropping
um and so you know the the ultimate real
requirement is more GPS to be able to
see the numbers of patients that are
coming through
um especially since demand for general
practice Services has gone up
dramatically in the last two years
the government's primary care plan will
also see high Street pharmacists taking
on more roles like prescribing
medication and it wants to train GP
receptionists to clinically assess calls
I don't think I'd be very comfortable
telling a receptionist my problems she's
not medically trained uq don't you for
ages on the phone and then you get
through and they say there's no
appointments left I think they should
staff it properly and then pay the staff
a proper wage I think that's that's the
best thing they can do everyone's shorts
left everyone's under pressure
and just throw in a load of cash at it I
don't think is the answer
assessment in technology to give
patients better access is welcome but
the challenge is to make sure there are
enough GPS like Dr Mehta to see those
patients
Joshi Sky News in Redbridge in Essex